are there any apologies
any conflicts of interest
all very quiet
we'll try to find the page
we'll move on to it three confirmations
by council of blackroom
discussion
i'll put the motion
three point one a confirm the minutes of
the orders meeting all in favor say iron
and i propose to carry
any matters arising from the marks
i had one material to start that you was
i asked chris
where the croquet club uh report was at
uh that's regarding the loan that
[Applause]
related all right thank you very much
listen here
uh we'll move on there are no
identifications
we'll come to the first report
6.1
uh
and he's speaking to that peace
thank you
thank you um
i don't know i am
so this report seeks approval
for a
congregation to the purpose
of the funding that we have currently
granted to uh
neighborhood support
uh
[Applause]
okay
so um this report seeks approval for the
uh variation to the purpose of the 3
uh dollars per year
excluding the dst that we grab to north
canterbury neighborhood support
and it also provides an overview
of a new strategic direction between
pendulum support and how these funds
might be utilized in line with that
um the report also acknowledges the the
value of neighbourhood park barbecues as
amendments for council staff and
effective members to effectively engage
with the community
and
also for the green space team to be able
to get some good formative information
around the potential redevelopment of
its places and spaces
and the report proposes that the
neighbourhood barbecues continue
uh but perhaps it's more of a focus on
the current delivery mode by the
community team and green space teams
i
just to give you a little bit of
contents we have supported north
canterbury neighborhood support for at
least 15 years uh council o'brien will
have a better understanding of me but my
understanding is we have supported him
for the past 15 to 20 years
with funding
to deliver neighborhood connection
and over that period neighborhood
support has been through
a series of
um
changes
as our community has changed so you may
remember that originally it was set up
as a
as a new street safe
and just making sure that
you know your residents weren't being
burgled that that people were being
looked after and it was a really strong
emphasis on the
street group
model
[Music]
and at that time the funding that we
gave them was just to encourage
neighborhoods for one big event um
they've been eventually died out
following the earthquakes north
canterbury neighborhood support went
through something of a hiatus
with that street lead model and started
to focus on building up a database
that would that would see people able to
access information and emergencies
over the period in which we diverted the
funding
um the first year went pretty well the
second year not so well and north
carolina with support
suffered
with um appear gaps in stamping that was
awesome
and
it's fair to say
that they needed some support to regroup
and get themselves back together so
community team and community development
staff have done quite a bit of work with
north carolina neighborhood support over
the last 12 months
and help them to
increase the capability of the
governance group
to develop a strategy
that will see them starting to create
meaningful
connection across the district and to
look at how they might implement that
strategy
alongside that um
what's the most successful avenue for
making sure that there is connection
level and are looking to return to that
group model
and looking at working with individual
communities as to how they can support
their more vulnerable residents identify
which resources can be shared
and create a really good sense of
community so
in light of all of that
we consider that the funds allocated to
north canterbury neighborhood support
would be best used
to progress
some of the projects associated with the
return to that model
and that
delivery of the barbecues continues
to be in line with business as usual for
the green space and community teams
and
as has been the case
deliver the gutter back
a share of the costs between those two
teams we feel that in terms of
neighbourhood connection across the
district
this is going to give them much better
outcomes for our communities and result
in more connected neighborhoods
particularly in those developing
communities and in some of our rural
communities
i will take the report as read but happy
to answer any questions
thank you
thanks tessa and thank you for the
report and explanation
uh have we have we had a conversation
with the north canterbury valley support
about uh undertaking this with sarah and
if yes what was the response
yes so so her conversation was driven by
canterbury neighborhood support you'll
be aware that
they engaged in interim manager in
february march of this year
and she's been very much involved in
looking at that new strategic approach
and it was suggested so she has given me
um
an overview of what they're proposing
and um
i'm very much in line with the thinking
that this has been a use of their
i was having undo
for a serious order yes okay thank you
thanks i could also say that councillor
atkinson and myself meeting sarah
sanders yesterday and had a discussion
um the good news is that funding for her
position has been extended for 12 months
so that's good news uh councilmember
[Applause]
my question is
have you seen recently the
river there and numbers have been
increasing through their gets ready
promotion campaign yes
so uh you will see detail and report and
i need to find the um
the particularly appropriate section but
they have seen quite a significant
increase
over the last six months
and that's directly as a result of their
having more capacity
and they are engaging directly with
people who are identified through vets
really tourists re-establish those
neighborhood groups so in the latest
flood response some residents obviously
received emails from them which were
quite pertinent have you given any other
feedback from the community about how
it's really is working to combine with
our civil defense initiatives
uh council lebron
so just just touching on that similar
things
[Music]
is
tool because used in emergencies
so there are sort of ongoing discussions
about how there can be
you know more value
out of that
i guess
in terms of this report our focus would
be on
the
the role that neighbourhood support
should have a neighborhood connection
and peace time as well
right no further questions
right we have a mover mr secondary
put the post by council blanket
my question because um
just interested to make sure that she
was uh with sarah and neighborhood
so thanks for the clarity on that
um i'm very encouraged with where
neighborhood support are going sarah
saunders has done to all of us and i'm
sure
i've worked with you
show and she's worked with a number of
organisations associated with achievers
are grateful for that with support very
well connected
it's a great organisation with a really
good objectivist i'm very pleased
that they are i think checking
themselves around us they were
um not functional but there were
obviously some areas they needed to
improve on and you know i think the
appointment of sarah and also the
continuing um
funding that was supportive of the year
a number of our community was
associated
which was really good so i never worked
in the community
i
was connected with a conversation with
brendan price that floods with sarah
and some of the members and they
certainly are going to be putting in a
bid
where they will land and net in
and what we are in a position to support
will be and obviously we'll need to
consider
serving this step here if they're in
support of that that's a great move and
furthers their objectives which i'm
impossible
thank you
councilman
yeah i just declare the mia's comments
sarah's a great asset
council of duty by councillor
thank you having been a few people we've
never had support for
the past
six years and stepped aside
this last team i'm really pleased to see
that they are moving forward
quite truthfully
as a sprint coordinator and all sorts of
things along the way as well and i've
seen a real change in their focus in
their strategic approach in the recent
times it's certainly been shown to be
beneficial in emergencies and they are
now linking in properly with certain
defense which may not have happened in
the past
and i think there's a great deal of hope
the the one that i would like to comment
on as councillor duty said is that most
other councils do fund their
neighborhood support groups we've had
some struggles with that because they
haven't been able to show proven value
show value to the community at the time
i think however with the new strategic
direction that might be something we
could reconsider going forward
what we need to see is results we need
to see how it's been useful to the
community and we need to get that
community feedback
and even in the small amount of change
that's going on in the last six months
i've certainly seen a lot more positive
feedback about network support um in the
role it can play in linking communities
i also agree with the diversion of the
money here and i have no vote
because obviously at the moment we can't
really do street barbecues under a level
two coveted situation and we're not sure
how long that's going to last it becomes
a bit problematic mixing people from
different areas so i'm very very
supportive of this and i hope that both
many will appear
[Applause]
thank you
sarah confirmed that neighbourhood
support had no desire to run street type
bbqs it's not part of their
plan if you like
they're still looking at connecting
communities
by a different way through the strength
model
they do have a crossover of course with
civil defense through the edge ready
program
so they sort of fit in the middle
between community and civil defence room
so it is very worthwhile and we have
every confidence in the
manager sarah cylinders
who is noted for actually getting
outcomes
so i think they'll make the progress
under her guidance
so
the 3200 will be i'm sure put to good
purposes but not in the uh physical
barbecue sets
right uh councilmembers
um i just like to add to those comments
that i too am pleased to see the strides
that neighborhood support is making
since sarah got on board and
the progress that they're making with
neighborhood support i also believe that
it is something that we as a council
should be in behind them doing because
it is quite an important civil defense
function as
my work with a lifestyle book side of
things
has also
highlighted i think
a connected community is a resilient
community and that's what we need is
resilient communities and that's what
they help deliver but i'm also very
happy to see that we do still cope
improvement and have the barbecues on
the table because whilst
they may sort of
waiver as to their effectiveness in some
other urban areas i know out in
our area they are very well
attended and um
quite cherished actually and we don't
have a lot of opportunity as a rural
community to get together and
you know come together as a community
and um do things like that so it's
really good if those things are still
facilitated because it gives us an
excuse to have something other than our
virtual town square so i'm very pleased
with the report and absolutely support
it thank you
thank you uh mr maybe one week you're
right fine it's all been very well
i don't remember
[Music]
say aye aye opposed
notions thank you
6.2 we're still with you tessa the year
in review
as chris and i commented
uh last week i think it doesn't seem
very long since the last report
sorry over here
yes it's easy to say that this year's
flying
um
so this
report provides an overview of the
community teams here in review report
and that details our activity in four
key areas so community development
community safety
youth development and civil defense
wealthy response and recovery
details the collaborative community-led
approach applied to the work of the
community team
in response to community team identified
need and priority
and results are measured um
both qualitatively
against um
their canterbury well-being index
measures population level and um
qualitatively in results results-based
accountability framework
do we know whether anyone is better off
i would particularly like to highlight
the role that this group plays in
enhancing the physical mental and social
well-being about communities
and um
councillor mila has talked about the
importance of having resilient
communities and if they're well
connected and supported
it's really easy
for for us to have positive social
outcomes for our residents
this work aligns directly with eight of
the united nations sustainable
development goals around equality
poverty and hunger health and well-being
safety sustainability and community
education
it also serves as a mechanism for
delivery of ten of council's community
outcomes
alongside this side i particularly would
like to highlight the role of the
community team
in social recovery from civil defense
emergencies
when
we first decided
to become the civil defence eoc welfare
team
it was an annual pandora exercise and
then we got back to our day jobs and in
recent years
this work is
made up quite a significant proportion
of the
community team and some really exciting
projects have come out of the social
recovery from covert 19 from earthquakes
and so forth
i'd also like to highlight the pastoral
support
that
this work sits outside business as usual
we are
pretty much an open door team
but the pastoral support is important
because it seems some see some of our
more vulnerable residents keep safe
and linked into community supports
and if you think about safety and
well-being with the
of the wider community that's really
important
i'll take the report best friend and
happy to answer any questions
all right have you any questions
none at the moment i'd like to
congratulate you on your report tessa
you and the community team are doing
awesome work and i think we're all very
pleased and proud of the work that
you're doing and that's showing them the
statistics and
fingers and the pies that you actually
manage to access
so it's
very good
good report
right well if there are no questions it
must be a very comprehensive report
is there a movement i'll move the report
a second
time
counselor
right
i've already spoken and given my
thoughts on the report it's an excellent
report and um
the community team are doing excellent
job
uh councillor duty would you like to
come
thank you very much that's a
well detailed report and very much
appreciate
um just showing exactly the worth of
your stuff during your mistakes
thank you
i think this has summarized everyone i
knew even your introductory remarks mr
chia
in a year like no other um really that
we've had so
and the one thing that i take is that i
think we're really fortunate to have a
staff in our community team particular
staff right across their organisation
that are very connected and caring of
individuals who need
support and that
through difficult times and not just
through difficult times through every
time really and
that's the thing that i think that this
team in your team that you need is they
really do make a difference
times of civil defense emergency with
other measures with floods
a really caring sign connecting with the
people the democracy
who were that
who had some really trying times
and i know i was able to reach out and
we were supporting them finding them all
the learners you name it
um you were there and your team were
there making sure that they were cared
for
they're proud of
what you and the team do
your exemplary
and you're an
and thank you for everything that you
and your team do
you wish to say
council members
had the pleasure of being involved in a
lot of these initiatives that you've got
in your year under court
um i can only say that i really just
applaud the
capabilities of
your amazing team and how they
uplift and empower and embrace
everyone large and small and everyone in
between no one falls between the cracks
and your community team our whole
community is pulled together with the
work that you do
and and if if there's a gap somewhere
you'll find it and you'll feel it
and you know there's really nothing to
love nothing not to love about that so
thank you and um
any further speakers
i want to exercise my wife reply but
i'll just endorse the comments made by
colleagues
i'll now put motion 6.2 amd
all in favor
i opposed
carrie
thank you
we now move on to item 6.3 library
update
so come forward
is to provide you all with an update
like to um a report and the report's a
bit smaller this time um you would have
noted um lockdown
has affected what we're able to do
but i'd like to draw your attention to
4.1
in particular library's evolving use of
social media
in july this year after the appointment
of as a replacement specialist digital
assistant with the expertise and social
media and website um in the combination
of the nzlcp
funded
social media training for three of the
libraries team and some of the
conference team
a library's social media strategy was
developed
um
lockdown was kind of a gift in a way as
it got us
gave opportunities for the team to test
the rigors of the
strategy and of its potential impact um
at the moment my microdermy libraries
use facebook instagram and twitter
and we are giving consideration to tech
talk and expanding our use of youtube as
well
constructive in our underlying word
constructive use of social media
platforms does offer an expensive range
of purposes to enable us libraries to
reach beyond our traditional users and
also beyond traditional event promotions
and information informative updates
at analytics for the last three months
in conjunction with the draft strategy
are proving that
the approach is working well i will put
a caveat in there that we do know that
we were we were a lock down
and we also had the phenomenal success
of the library the down at your
libraries
to generate more traffic
but um
additional things outside of those few
things that could have skewed data do
prove that the new strategy is working
so you'll see that growth on last year
is close to 380 percent
with approximately two likes uh an
average of two likes per post pre-dage
per day
um in the past our facebook posts were
predominantly infomercial advertising
what we are already doing
which served our served quite well and
it serves our traditional
users quite well
facebook gives us an opportunity to
increase engagement with those beyond
our traditional audience and demonstrate
connections that they might not have
seen with their library service
it's also giving us opportunities to
grow the diversity of our audiences and
amplify our messages through partner
networks
examples of that would be promotions
recently before lockdown of our lgbtqi
plus events in utopia in christchurch
amplifying our messages
during lockdown
my book bag service for vulnerable
people in our community
was it was picked up by
lately children
of elderly parents in the district the
ugly parents were following us on
facebook that they were connecting with
us through our facebook page to try and
get things for their parents
our voice our social media voice has
been carefully home to reflect that that
you would get when you come into our
library there's often been um
a gap between what people might
experience when they come in and what
they experience online and the
importance of that consistency of voice
and our brand and that chattiness to
ensure that people feel comfortable has
been really really whipped on in
conjunction with
the social media training and best
practice of the libraries are
experiencing
people have asked us
are we moving away from the traditional
poster in a window or an advertisement
to the local user newspaper and it
really depends on the demographic for
the event or the activity or the program
that we're offering
we know
that
more retired people may see a post in a
newspaper but equally so they may be
growing their skills and expertise in
the social media area so in those cases
it's an end and end but if we're looking
for preschool promotion for activities
after school most of the parents that
would be bringing their children along
will be in the facebook space so we're
channeling our energy
and not checking out channeling our
resources and to be advertising with
that print-based
media
facebook is continuing um you'll
remember from last lockdown it gave us
the agility to create programs from home
and this recent lock down and did that
even more with crafting clubs and puppet
shows in addition to the toddler times
baby times nursery
all uploaded by the team on mostly their
own devices at home
we're going to continue to weave in some
of the backend process processes of
libraries to connect the community with
new books coming in there's been some
interesting instagram posts of boxes of
new books getting unpacked on video and
then people come off asking her to order
those straight away
facebook is also offering us
opportunities to have a very low cost
apart from staff time
and when we're doing western posts we're
only looking at very minimal investment
i'd like to draw your attention to 4.3
just a few posts a few points of
the library service during lockdown
so and
at level three and four we took 270
email enquiries from the community
and it followed up with phone calls and
in-depth phone calls with many people
across the district who were new to our
services
and tech help and my team reported that
in some cases these calls were an hour
and a half
again they were referrals from from
children for
their parents to get connected with our
ebooks to keep connected with our
resources
and there was a whole ah quite a
significant social component too to
those calls
the team were incredible and i went into
lockdown that was the night we all last
met and an email was sent to them all at
ten past six
and
over half of the team came back in that
night and took their equipment took
their computers books over processing
folders of work so they were able to
work from home
you'll see the figures um for the first
few total number of visits for the first
three days are roughly double
we came back at level two roughly double
but we are noticing a significant drop
of people coming into the library as a
boot as case numbers are
rising and lastly um i know that uh mr
mia you're quite interested in local
history so i'll draw your attention to
4.4 this is a lpp
initiative or it's an idea shared from
the nzlp and initiative through
one of the local history coordinators
street names here today so it's a
scheduled post on facebook where a local
street name
street sign is posted
and then the followers
of the library's facebook page share
their knowledge their
stories their history um
and out of the woodwork is coming a
collection of stories that sally and
beth will then curate into something
that can last for a longer time
on our website and hopefully a platform
so
that's great and creating quite a lot of
interest and so it was interviewed about
that on campus again this morning
i'll take any questions during right
thank you paula um you didn't mention or
if you did i missed it somewhere in your
report i think you referred to the uh
video that your staff
produced yesterday
just under 30 000 views oh
so
it's gone viral right are there
questions
yes
um
right to move the recommendation that i
want to enter you see
which uh
series congratulates library's manager
paul esker on being awarded a lanza
association in the end of the fellowship
in the end zone
um
in addition to what paul is already
another outstanding team
here in that video that was produced
through lockdown was fantastic um
really was but i want to focus
i got a letter sent to me just the other
day
advising me that paula had been awarded
this and i wanted to recognise that
knowing this meeting was coming up was
to recognize that today
and if you could just indulge me i'd
like to read the citation
paula's library career started in
christchurch libraries before i moved to
richmond high school as the library
manager initially at the school
elena is part of the upper russian
school and community library she has
carried this passion for learning
teaching and research throughout your
career
as a content writer for the open
polytech ris courses
and services to schools of the national
library who work with core education
where she was the first non-teacher to
be awarded a poor education in
fellowship
and to the ends of advocacy as a mentor
to colleagues throughout the profession
paula has served on the lienzo iraqi
committee was the convener of the anza
2017 conference
and was lianza president 2018 to 2019
she has represented lyanza and iefla
including the world library and
information congress bid government
ministers and on multiple forums
paula is currently a commissioner for
the library and information advisory
commission
paula has been a local advocate for the
contribution that libraries make to the
un's sustainable development goals
as a result of her passion she has
represented new zealand on the topic to
audiences in australia canada portugal
bangladesh
and across the world by zoom
highlighting the possibilities and the
achievements of new zealand
in the syria
she has been heavily involved with
promoting creative commons
receiving an lol 2 fellowship to the
institute of open leadership
in south africa presenting a creative
column at commons
global summits and as a graduate of the
creative commons global certificate
program
who shares your knowledge and skills
willingly having published multiple
research papers being interviewed on the
radio
and presenting at multiple conferences
every year
paula's continued exceptional advocacy
but warm and enthusiastic representation
of lyansa and new zealand
and to a range of achievements make her
a worthy recipient of the anza
fellowship we are incredibly proud of
you well done
[Applause]
i think the reason the report speaks for
itself
thank you thank you for the indulgence
thank you mr mayor
um
if we just parked the motion up for the
moment are there any questions before
in this room oh so we can't listen to it
now no
it's it's still going through our
facebook page so we get the traffic
so i'll try and change that the next
time all right
i noticed one of the things we were
looking at was title
i saw a
documentary on tit talk the other day
that
there needs to be caution uh with the
choosing view of the data that's
collected and how it may be used
absolutely are other libraries using tit
talk as part of the social media suite
yes with caution and the little account
waves as contained as possible so um
that yeah
the reference to the creative commons
aspect of the fellowship
it's a huge that awareness of what's
done with people's data and how it's
used is a huge part of
front of mind for me on if and how we
would use tiktok
but is definitely the privacy issues
aware of that more of us creating
content for people to use and us
accepting other people's content for our
platform that way we can
create keep it ethical keep it contained
and keep the attributions
um yeah really tight
right thank you that's good
you're the right person to keep an eye
on the top i can tell
are there any further questions before
oh my my question was kind of in line
with that but um
yeah i really like how you were
how you're tailoring the information you
put out too which um
demographic that you're looking to reach
because it's a really good use of
resources um but are you able to measure
the demographics um following the
other platforms like insta
instagram twitter etc
at the moment i don't think we're
getting a lot we're not getting a lot of
traffic through instagram um it's it's
very very new up until very recently it
was um
and it was actually pre what it was the
last library's manager they were doing
sort of an instagram friday with the
book cover in person
um it's it's just starting now so you
know i've got a lot of data at the
moment
facebook is giving us a lot of analytics
um and we've got to drill down even more
there to the demographic we are starting
a bit of a sequence part of the lpp
offerings has been
six of us
are doing a year-long course
on
research and engagement and we're
learning how to get better metadata how
to get better data from the people who
are attending our things and feedback so
that's all for just a paper based as
well surveys in person that have to hear
about so it's a working process progress
is a short answer
that's great because i do know that
just having a variety of different
social media users in my own household
there are different demographics using
the different things kind of
you know age from here to here um also i
just have to say i love your street name
saturday i didn't even know that
woodfield's road um
i always thought it was a woodfield
honestly i didn't know it was named
after oakfield so
thank
[Music]
about i do like the idea of
this
history
um so
would you like us to
have some history
a year left of the nzwp and they're
wanting to get as much content
as much
local
like with many local stories local boys
so absolutely
the
other one i want to just ask you about
is that
how are you progressing with your that
digital um uh speaking to people you
know getting the history
system trends there were 16 transcripts
that were done quite a while ago that
were
temporarily misplaced and found last
week are about to be digitized the team
are exploring platforms
um
and that may be a future paper at the
beginning of next year around um you
know what sort of platform we would put
this on
tim also working with comms as a
platform that we weren't aware of
exploring possibilities for the
digitisation of the local stories the
the voice recordings um the photos
so all of that's underway at the moment
we're getting heavily supported by
christchurch libraries and their local
history specialists um and some people
our top alexander turnbull library to
around best practice around
the recording the
backing metadata and how we preserve
this for a potentially a future that
that format might not exist
so
the museums
so uh they have met with each of
kaiakoi oxford and changi moore
had in person meetings in rangiora
library and out there as well we're
doing some sally and youth night at the
moment of doing some work on creative
commons on how we can
support the museums to retain the
copyright of the information they have
by making it accessible to others
and
again referring back to that study to
bring the best practice and so those
served communities served and the
information is made accessible without
compromising the
interaction without compromising the
copyright owners rights
a series of booklets called heritage
trials
you can check on that too
i've got i've still got the video
somewhere find it but um
by myself uh any further discussion on
the motion
like i just like to say i think it's
very good motion and thank you mr
bringing that to our attention
so the motion is
6.3 abcmd
the new c replaces
the scene that was in the agenda
if you wish to exercise your life
requirements
all right i'll put the motion all the
time
opposed
thank you very much paula and
congratulations on
thank you very much
all right we'll move on to item 6.4
what that's october update
i'm not sure who i have to bribe to get
my position changed in the agenda but
there are some very
very big shoes to fill under those two
yeah so the purpose of this report is to
update the community and recreation
committee on the operation and goings-on
and the aquatic facilities
um i'd like to i'll take the reporters
read it up and draw your attention to a
couple of the points uh 4.1 and 6.1
firstly uh being the attendance and the
financial impacts
obviously with covert
the recent block downs and then the
ongoing restrictions
we've seen quite a few impacts
especially over our leisure swim
lines of income
and income and ticket sales as with
previous restrictions
we're seeing both
customers who are getting
um
a little bit snappier as restrictions go
on and um also customers who really
appreciate that the ether that we the
team are going to to ensure that they
that keep safe but that we're able to
continue to operate within the
guidelines and keeping customers and
staff safe at these times so it's both
both a bit of a balancing act
in 4.3 we had the staffing update um
this uh the report highlights our
ongoing concerns around staffing
um within both the facilities and the
industry in general uh we've been taking
steps and we're currently in the process
of recruiting a number of low-level
positions however the
shortage of high-level senior level
staff is continues to be a concern for
the wider industry
as we've discussed previously
christchurch are only continuing to open
more facilities and they all need staff
and and that so we're working within the
industry uh and with our ito to try and
address this and
fill those fill those gaps
in 4.4 it highlights our response to the
recent
level 3 level 4 and level 3 restrictions
and our ongoing steps that we're taking
to keep customers safe as i said there's
a mixed response from the community
a bit of wariness as well as
a lot of understanding most recently we
changed our approach that we're taking
to mask wearing
the initial guidance implied that mars
had to be born at all times on poolside
uh updated wording on the website and
implied that
it was to be
supported but not mandatory in a
poolside environment which is
understandably more damp environment so
we updated we worked with some customers
and updated that process
and i'm happy to take any questions
all right thank you matt
any questions
the entire community is being impacted
and so um people are doing as well as
can be and the the current code
restrictions allow us to actually manage
the customers um one one of the aspects
where we differ from christchurch is a
lot of our customers unprefer required
time and so current our current
processes we're blocking customers into
lane space and they would long love to
see that continue um it's it's been a
winner so that allows us to manage
the time they come and that's that's
working really well for us and for
starting the community and allows us to
to smooth those peeps the scaler phrase
from ashley bonfire
the other question i just might join is
can you
you know try to get
people interested in joining your
facility have you thought about going to
the high schools and actually speaking
with them have you done that
um i spoke with emily
as well as
one of the ladies in
hr has some connections with oxford so
um we got that one circulated through
the school as well so yeah that's that's
yeah we'll learn are these things
councilor barney
just speaking of high schools and i've
had opposite feedback from obviously our
teenagers who are finding it very
restrictive under the covered
environment i just wondered is there any
opportunity to
book the leisure call for more activity
than what is currently being offered
it's a very fine balance and and
one that within the industry no one's
finding a silver bullet for so i i
believe christchurch are doing you book
the whole and you must distance but it's
very select numbers um with the approach
we've taken is splitting the call up
into different spaces i fully appreciate
that that just won't work for some
people um
it's it's it's a really fine edge to try
and find something that works for the
majority
um in these times so yeah i i definitely
take your point that it's not satisfying
everyone um
yeah we're continuing to we talk weekly
within the industry about
what are you trying what have you
probably did this work for this month so
yeah at this point we've got no real
silver
silver bullet to fix this issue yeah
unfortunately
right no further
questions
i'll move to 6.5 a a to c that's there
just like thank you for your
report
martin in trying times swimming at level
two
um
i wonder if you may have come up with
waterproof masks or something that
could be
an avenue there to investigate
ryan councilman
thanks thank you very much for your
report appreciate it
and i think perhaps i need to shift you
around to the first one
we should be changing should be
alternating it
could be
counselor
yes thanks matt just um to redirect my
comments with me in any way reflecting
on the pool at all i just find it
absolutely ridiculous that eighteen
hundred students go to rooney high
school every day with no math and travel
around classrooms and yet we can't have
a group of teenagers
in the leisure pool at a particular time
or anything like that because of the
fact that the covert regulations are
just so scrambled
and these young people are missing out
they're missing out on leisure and
recreational opportunities
i fully appreciate you've done
everything to manage the roles but the
rules are ridiculous and if we're going
to continue to allow
um schools to mingle in this way
teenagers should also have the
opportunity to recreate in this way as
well um i do not i i appreciate the lane
issue but if that's the case we need to
dedicate a lane to our teams and have a
bring around high school and kind of
work high school and home school now and
maybe that will work
thank you council of only times
at the point you make i think the rules
are a bit of a mess
um
ideally we should be in level one at the
moment you could argue
what you make your life a lot easier man
and no doubt librarians
by any further discussion
for being none i won't exercise my right
to reply
i'll motion
uh 6.5 a to c all in favor
aye opposed
carrie thank you man
underwriting seven i have no
correspondence
uh
the mayor has presented his
correspondence
item eight portfolio updates um
yes
[Music]
thank you um
i'd just like to say it's uh
i'm alright with the order
um it's actually really nice because
they uh put you a little great before i
tuna
to be here i think um just reflecting on
what my colleagues have done
um over the last year with uh with what
they've done with polls and libraries
and also community support and
development as well it's um it's
actually really nice to kind of work
within a team and the thing that chris
has pulled together so
it's really nice for us to sit back and
come here all of those warm comments i
think it's actually really nice
i see the work that they do and it's
it's great to actually see that
knowledge especially at this table so
thank you i should also acknowledge your
accountability by ryan
yet welcome
distanced himself
yes he's an appropriate
um
so uh
good day everybody good luck
yes
yes have a good afternoon um so this
report's ready to kind of highlight the
community and recreation
the workplace in the green spaces
doing post um you know was a relatively
ambitious ltp in terms of the workplace
that we've seen ourselves
um kind of just giving a bit of an
update as to where some of the projects
are at what we quite like to do and
one of the things that uh ryan's
actually living on the heart of
community and recreation because you
know there's some uh projects in here
from that as well
um it's really gonna make sure that
we're keeping the lines of communication
with
you as the elected members of the
elected committee
around community and recreation but also
making sure that
we're going out to the boards and just
kind of keeping them up to date with
what we're doing around our capital our
capital program
and our plan something that uh chris has
identified a thousand
uh and others have as well as that
sometimes we're not really given the
visibility that people might want around
some of the projects that we're doing or
they might not hear for a while around
some of the things that you know we kind
of incentive to do
um you're in touch with your community
quite regularly and you know they're
probably going to know some of these
things around
um so we kind of want to run through
that let you know where we're at um some
of the challenges that we're sort of
facing just in terms of trying to do the
delivery around those
um
and also just to kind of field any
questions or anything that you want to
kind of add into this knowing that this
is kind of a new thing for us that we're
doing
so i wanted to make sure early on that
you're involved in the discussion piece
around that so look i'll take the report
as read
but if you are all right
through the chat
i might run through the table
just to update and myself and write it
here to kind of just answer any
questions that you might have
is that suitable for you yes carry on
brian
um so you see there's what we
what we've done is actually kind of
listed things that are according to the
community outcome that they sit under
um
we've got a variety of boxes in there
and we're kind of regarding this as we
go so
a little bit of what we've got
today is
um without turning into a full-blown
workshop
um it's just kind of making sure that
these are the sorts of things that you
think would be better to be updated on
um
i really wanted to try and give you a
bit of a heads up as to where some of
these some of these projects are at um
and maybe you know if there's anything
new that you were surprised might not be
within us
the one thing that i would say with this
is that a lot of that's the project work
that we're doing a lot of other things
we kind of see is business as usual
that hasn't necessarily moved into the
report so
this isn't
technically everything we're doing but
it's just some of the highlights that we
wanted to make sure that you're aware of
in terms of in terms of
what
the units working on
so you can see here there's the
community facilities asset
management
so that's something that andy coca and
his team have picked up um posts on kong
being here um ryan's going to be linking
the glue there so he's
working with them on that um you'll note
in the ltp we have general landscaping
budgets report so that report is still
pending
um so we've got some work to do from the
ltk around there so we're envisaging
that that's going to be back with
the walls
and community and recreation probably
around about march next year
um
the ice sports building you'll note that
chris had already submitted a report
um
a sports facility satisfaction survey
that's an annual thing that we're doing
and that's really just making sure that
we're asking questions out to our sports
users and kind of linking over there
the citizen community hall project
myself and india are working
on that at the moment they've got a
meeting tomorrow night
we've sent them a litter of
intent in terms of what it is that we're
going to be doing as a council moving
forward and kind of through the through
the process of that
um
community centre they had a meeting on
monday night last night um which andy
led so i believe councillor nixon and
um he's doing a great job excellent
it's hard to train people these days
uh
we stocked with reserve as well so we've
got some government money to help us
with that so that's going to be the
program that's actually intended um one
that my coffee is visible with you that
i wanted to put in here was actually
pretty worked up for my matches
[Music]
we're actually attending
monthly meetings around that one of the
really exciting
we've actually got a couple of warm-up
games occurring here
um
peter devlin is
pretty excited about that so they're
doing some work down at main power over
but it's really good for us
we've got
the highest rankings seen in the world
the indian women's cricket team we're
going to be playing two matches here
um we know that south africa is coming
but we
we're hopefully going to find out where
the other hot fire is shortly
so there's some things that we do again
with them um around promotions that
christchurch nz might be able to bring
out our way
um and i've got another meeting with
them
as well so we're trying to make sure
that there's some visibility and
actually some effort going into into our
areas and not just christchurch as well
um
there'll be a report coming around the
regeneration land requests and that's
really around there's been quite a few
neighbors have started to put their
hands up to actually buy back some of
the regeneration area
um
on that
the options here um
some of the some of the issues and
concerns that we might have
uh the town entrances strategy and
budget implementation plan that's
ongoing another thing from the ntp
southpark feasibility we're expecting to
have that report back by the end of this
week which would be really good because
we can then present that
next in our meeting
uh the land purchase for pegasus and
ravenswood
there's not really a lot that i can
update on that at this point in time it
continues to be an ongoing conversation
we're still learning towards having a
willing seller
um
fixings road cemetery has been resource
consented
so there's just something based on work
there through the district cleaner also
with
some of the landowners throughout that
area as well
the pines beach splash pad we've
actually got a consultant engaged to
work on that that's a request that come
forward through the ltv
so that's
why do we need a consultant to build a
splash pad is to know what expertise are
they bringing that you guys haven't got
yeah so they're not that's it's not
necessarily a building and it's just
with the amount of work that we've got
on
we can't do it within the timeframe
that's been said
so in essence what the consultant's
doing is
pushing that on through the community
consultation process
yeah it's not necessarily about design
it's about whether or not we're going to
do it yeah and answering some of those
questions that came through for me on tv
but as i said it's quite an ambitious
work plan
with some um unfortunately with some
negative vacancies that we haven't been
able to fill
uh we kind of have to look around how we
can still get things
for the community
um so cardboard playing ground provision
so that's been reported back up through
to ktc there
uh
and that's on track at this point in
time but we do believe that it's going
to be at risk
heading forward especially with some of
the feedback that we're getting around
acquiring equipment
what we're noticing is anytime there's a
playground project whether it's
ourselves or christchurch or salem
um it's taking months um for equipment
to get here even the components that are
built with the museum
the lockdown notebook hasn't helped and
that's where a lot of things are
actually emanating from
as well as the fact that we still order
the majority of our playground equipment
comes from overseas
and that's just because the new zealand
market doesn't do it at all
so that's that is a genuine risk that
we've
that got
slightly concerned about so obviously
we've got replacement components here
that'll be okay for our current stock
but going forward for new playgrounds
there's a there's a slight concern
you'll see there's a static monitoring
project there that's ongoing at this
point in time um glets and double park
entrance will be a workshop at the next
oxford worker board
we've had a new entrant into the work
plan an exciting one around the wakuku
master plan that's just because we've
got a number of projects here that are
all tied together in a limited amount of
space in which to deliver more
so we've got to set some expectations
with the board and also with the
community there about what we can do and
kind of have some of that community
engagement
the rival club that's definitely one
that at this point in time is at risk
we're trying to work on that through the
work that we're doing with cast
in the community centre but
the issue remains it's not as easy for
us to just set them up somewhere
some of the regulations that they've got
and the fact that they're still wanting
to use leak bullets
is not easy for us to resolve
as
nick had said there's no silver bullet
around there
but the big thing is that we could
probably resolve the issue if we get a
different kind of material
but the lead is the biggest issue
and
yeah there's
there's going to be a lot of
conversations around that a lot of
negotiation with the club for that
sorry i wasn't going to
ask
um i'm just wondering if perhaps it may
be with while you're speaking to the
oxford and p
association
that's uh that's great um we can
certainly do that as part of that
project as well because we're looking
wherever we can get them
the reality is we don't have a purpose
building but they can't stay where
they're currently at
um security camera network plans so
that's currently under construction uh
under construction it's under authorship
um we're having meetings with community
watch the police
and also some of the providers around
that
um the natural environment strategy
action plan is currently being authored
through
uh
brian hospital and the policy thing
um i don't know
that's ongoing work although we are
currently trying to get a project
manager in place for that
um and also you'll know
sorry
i mean
i'm just going to mention this with your
stops
and double trump that we have
intelligent that we have um the diligent
we're looking at that's where they
stopped but i've just emailed everyone
in the report which is actually the
report which is in our trend document
and the list continues so i need to just
stop here and catch and keep talking
just going back to the regeneration land
requests so can you just clarify what is
it that people you say that non-private
um landowners are wanting to purchase
regeneration land for what purpose can
you just elaborate a little bit
to have a bigger section
joining land right next to their so they
want land that's right next to the house
um
yeah there's a there's a number of
requests that have come through for it
uh
it's mostly in relation to just having a
big backyard
when you're looking at um the
main power
oval uh
um thank you that's actually a really
good question so peter didlin has gone
and acquired
funding through
the national funding round that they had
for
hosting the women's credit world cup
one of the difficulties that they've had
in my empire is the fact that it has
been single sets
um they've now created
it very rocky
um they've now upgraded their facilities
to the unisex and uh much nicer so we're
gonna go and have a look through those
sometime in the next couple of weeks
um
beta linked to great pains to make sure
that uh
jes from
canberry cricket was well aware of the
fact that they got six hundred thousand
dollars
and
what peter has managed to achieve with
only forty five thousand dollars so
yeah
um he was just making clear that you
know we've got walmart matches as well
as salman
as well as uh
other areas
and
the level of funding hasn't quite been
equitable so but what they've done has
been fantastic
because
we'll we'll definitely do that i'll be
speaking
[Applause]
launch of the cricket season uh it was
really strongly acknowledged the
partnership with our council
and the fact that they value the
relationship with grant and his team
um the president mentioned that several
times and his comments and then
further followed up by peter just how
badly that is and how appreciative they
[Music]
so it's very nice to
know you were here hear
well
um but certainly i'm very nice to hear
within our years that
we've given that we give and
hirodelli and others perceive the
nature that they they may simply like to
consider a contribution
if you'd like to carry on with your list
and if colleagues want to actually have
it in front of them
email yeah
it's got a word document um
um
um so to cook this correct toilet uh
actually chris met with doc yesterday so
i don't know if you wanted to say
anything around that one chris
yeah they were
really collaborative actually they are
wanting to undertake their consultation
with the community and partnership with
us but there they'll go on and undertake
it with
some staff support
um they
have said that they don't have any
funding at the moment similar to us not
having any funding however if it was a
partnership approach where there was
funding by
us at the local authority then
they would be able to potentially get
some funding
from department of conservation at least
in the next
sort of eight months to a year i think
that was probably more aligned to our
annual plan and we could bring something
to our annual plan so we're going to do
a concert plan with the community some
consultation bring it back to the end
plan with some costumes um
we both agreed that um
it's probably more in that location so
we're not expecting it to be that
expensive but great to see
open to a really good collaboration on a
joint project
the next one that you'll see on the word
was there is the pest control report so
we're actually going to wrap that up
into the natural environment strategy
slash action plan so they'll be
reporting as part of that project
um
unfortunately the industrial grounds
process has
suffered somewhat with a long-term staff
absentee
it's not work that i've been able to
pass on to anybody on the rest of the
team but we're currently
working to address that with a fixed
term
a um
term position or
actually working on the return to work
program with the staff member in
question um has been delayed a little
bit so
we're hoping that we can get that right
back up and running
at the moment that
has been supported by jacob maxwell and
the policy team anyway so it's been
really good to have her available to us
there
um the ball's road suspension bridge um
again that's one that we've
got a consultant working on and again
that's just really around community
engagement
so that's the engagement project
the bringing our town hall setting
we've actually got a briefing
once i
wrap up
the ringer town hall hvac
that's actually completed
and is
right as well
no
yeah so it's operating really well
the cardboard community hub said there
was an update last night to the
collarboy to a kaikohe community board
um just outlining the fact that uh i'm
going to be doing some consultation
through the resource consent
from this point on
uh
and
last but not least um the eff master
plan
um has been out for tender so that we
could get a specialist on board to help
us with that one
we've had one person come forward thus
far so we are currently doing some work
with them around
the kind of service that they might
actually be able to provide to us um
unfortunately
as we're seeing a lot of things the
market hasn't really responded the way
that we were hoping um
and we didn't get the
uh i guess range or numbers of
companies interested that we were hoping
we did chase up
a few people post that
but we haven't quite managed to entice
anybody else to look forward or put the
hand up yet
um
so thank you for allowing me to kind of
run through that uh with you i guess we
just wanted to make sure that you're
aware of what it is or where some of
these projects were at
um there's a number that aren't
necessarily on there but it's just
purely because we kind of see them as
business as usual
um a couple that you might be wondering
where they are is like other places um
[Music]
as well
um so you look i'll i'll take the report
that's read and it is read out
and if you're taking any of the
questions that you might have
thank you grant
yes but i'll just ask you some of the
work
is a risk because of the length of
staff resources
um
what is the position in your
department at the moment for the number
of arguments
[Music]
i don't think it's necessarily just an
issue for community recreation i think
it's an issue um not just for a heart
local authority either it's an issue
nationally
in a lot of different professions where
we are finding where we have um staff
leaving positions
it's difficult to feel
at the moment the time period is staking
to fill in um
is quite long
and and it's really difficult to
actually find people for those positions
as well so
a lot of it is
due to
positions not being filled and there are
some vacancies
to vacancies at the moment and a third
vacancy coming up
um with kevin dwyer
resigning as well
um so we had michelle flanagan league
and then we're really big on the team
with the amount of work that she could
actually do with being out to the market
for that position couldn't find anyone
suitable we've gone out to the market
again for that and it's currently open
at the moment we have a community
facilities role and it's about to go to
market and we have case studies
currently not there so there's sort of
three positions within a relatively
small team
and that has a massive impact on our
ability to be able to actually do work
in addition to that
um
we do use consultants
too and we and when i say consultants
there sometimes just means pdu
but pdu are not in a wonderful position
either at the moment with the
availability of engineers
to be able to actually complete a lot of
work at the moment they are really
struggling with
other consultancies
taking staff pre three waters
et cetera et cetera so
it has flown effects for us and the
delivery of some of our projects as well
you can be assured that grant's doing
everything he can to think outside the
box and
we've been able to secure a really good
consultant um tara who some of you met
um ktcv meeting last night she's an
expert in doing consultation so being
able to have someone that can sit in the
office and just get that consultation in
the community done means we'll be in a
better position to deliver some of those
projects
um
grant's always working closely with our
hr team to try and fill the vacancies
which are there at the moment so
it's not it's not through lack of money
in the budget
that's a lack of being able to get good
staff in the positions and unfortunately
some citizens as well
well man referred to that's one thing
so it's across the board yeah and
libraries are feeling the same pinch as
well um and then that's weight as well
with um uh you have some resignations
and staff stepping um sideways and the
ability uh time attacks to fill those as
well so
and it's not just our local authority
it's across the board and
um but we're doing everything we can um
and the staff are really you know
stepping up in a lot of areas to take on
extra work and
um and hopefully um we can we can fill
all those vacancies and do what we need
to do so they don't just keep doing that
thank you
any other questions for granted
we're at risk
obviously we want to achieve as many as
we possibly can
and cross it out some of these involved
with that but that's
council
and things are probably slightly more
difficult at the moment than i've ever
ever known them
however we will get there in the end
and it's just a matter of being patient
and not creating too much expectation in
some of those communities such as why
coffee beach
because once you say yes that's a really
good idea at council meeting all of a
sudden there's an expectation that
you're going to be delivering it
yesterday
so but i'm sure the team can manage city
expectations
and bearing in mind i've just been
taking over 15 years since i
started work this morning i'm slightly
disappointed to hear the crackhead
opening
um
you know i just can't believe it
the green space
um
[Music]
but if you'd like to go i'm happy to
make sure you're included in our list i
don't think peter and that would mind
in the future
but there's only one representative from
each of the
there was one from salman
which was representing the near
married bank that was all there was
there wasn't other councillors including
amazing rights it was a very small group
i think especially so this year because
of goldman but um i'll take the boat in
there for next year
thank you any further questions
right now we have a movie
and secondly
[Applause]
but i really appreciate this
you know support before this that's
great i really appreciate that let's
keep this up to date with you
yes it looks like a fairly ambitious
program so good luck to you all and
hopefully you can find the resourcing
that you are required to deliver
and now we understand the position room
you didn't wish to sign the wrote a
reply
right i'll put motion
6.5 a to c all in favor say hi
thanks very much
we have
no correspondence
i've made portfolio updates
first up is council of brian
green space operations the remedial we
can actually gorge for in the recent
storm has nearly been completed
treatment travels have been replaced
along the playground
have been sown
chemical cemetery legs in progress with
new burial burns planted rainbow
economically in oxford until the fences
in our place has been stained to prolong
the acid life and
preserve and improve the reserve
appearance
and a lot of cameras being installed in
pearson overlapping help reduce
potential damage to the toilet block and
community garden another cameras plant
planned for
morgan williams reserve and coyote
biodiversity actually gorge top soiling
level and hydro city completed
temporary fencing done to prove the risk
of vehicles driving out of new
grasslands public vehicle access to
reserve reopens actually working very
history car park stop painting counter
completing works this week with solo
swirling honda seating and replacing
fencing ptp ranges funding round four
now underway
proc stock jobs for nature funds of
approximate 90k
ranges will also have undertaken project
and maintenance of some natural areas of
bio-diversity areas including our tear
tire which ranges have been changing
1600 ceilings sealings of
2 000 additional planting following the
initial community planting of 2019
silver stream village for period
planting ranges assisted planting over
500 ceiling seedlings with local
residents and silver stream observed
volunteers
this is a joint project with ecan so the
stream reserve plant approx 5 000
seamless this season involving community
plantings for the number of crafts
on the forest eleven hundred ceilings
planting in a planet as in for the
community planting groups 600 ceiling
seedlings planted it in new areas and
site maintenance ops
coyote river riparian plantings and wind
control and taken for three waters incan
funded
taranaki reserve 280 seedlings planted
and maintained even reserves school
plantings maintained on the forest
community planting day was held 18th of
september planting approximately 600
segments capital project restaurants for
12 projects underway following funding
received as part of the tourism
infrastructure fund this has all been
put out tenure and staff are now
evaluating the submissions ash key
reserve staff are currently
investigating options to resolve the
drainage issues in the cafe that have
bought to be taken to the collaborate
community
reserve roads and car park renewals is
currently out for tinder and it's
programmed to be
completed over the spring summer months
it's not reserved uh staff have received
a price to complete the work on the
trees and endothelials are the last
plant this will be completed in the
coming weeks thank you very much
[Music]
um because council does give them
funding towards that they don't feel
that it's sufficient
um the oxford arts gallery and chris and
i are going to
meet up with the arts gallery
tomorrow
they just wanted to do some
beautification and
i mean they're going to be gifted a
piece of art
a sculpture by the late louis summers so
he used to live in oxford
so the family would think i want them to
have this
not the one that was at the library at
that
and i just like to say thank you to the
staff very much for uh which the roles
are disgusting right um the recent storm
in particular pearson park where 232 i
think the sequoias were there
[Music]
big trees
but two of them built in and they just
narrowly
missed all the playground equipment
and they but obviously that those trees
were tidied up on the ground sweetened
and you wouldn't even know that the
break
a bit of um so earlier you already know
that you've been there so just like to
say thank you very much to the who did
that really appreciate it because it was
very quick
um we've been to
some property acquisition and disposal
meetings um we'll also have some
housing
social adorable
workshops
uh restocks in reserve and we're
thrilled about that this toilet's going
to happen there
um
so beautiful
the
community
committee there they were around there
and they were very disappointed and had
people come in and thought that the
planning that they've done far better at
their house
so um
you know they really work hard and i'm
great that that twerk goes in there
gonna work even harder
the oxidation peas committee i
them about
locating it on their ground
they are having
problems
with um
the locals seem to think that their
private land is an extension of the
reserve and they have a great deal of
difficulty with people with dogs walking
so they'll be hopefully this dog park
can start so they can get them
it's been a really busy time and
unfortunately with comet
and
we've not been able to meet the same
i've just found it really difficult
um
trying to catch up my portfolio
chris and i do talk lots of fortnight
sometimes if we can you know
which helps me to keep update on this
one but it's really just a moment
um i just want to get back into meeting
with the staff again because it's
something
short
all right mr one dude
any questions of
wendy
uh 8.4 arts and culture council of latin
thank you
um a few things our ypat wymack
public arts trust is up and running um
our signature um
event was putting the black balls 150th
anniversary andrew drummond sculpture on
the riverbank which you you've all seen
and some of you were there um gone ahead
and we're very pleased with that and
it's spinning happily in the inevitable
easterly i don't think it's stopped
since they put it in next year or the
west
or the south
um
the the pose at um the entrance to
pegasus that they they've been passed
over to waipa um in a moral sense for us
to look after too and as you as you all
know we've allocated funding for their
repair and maintenance at the moment and
whitehead will take them over and and
and
open discussions um
down the lines for the future for future
maintenance
um kaipou expo have very generously
donated a large sum of their profit
money this year to waipat to put another
sculpture somewhere in cairport probably
on the riverbank and we're working on
where that can be spent at the moment
with with relevant artists
we've also been donated by chris
marshall in a hoka a
metal
sculpture called the gathering which he
he
was disposing
of and it is currently gracing my barn
at the moment while i frantically pour
crc into it to try and get it it's got a
spinner on it in the wind too which
doesn't spin because it's seized but
we're working on that um and then we'll
find a place to put that some somewhere
in
in in the district we haven't made any
plans with that
the tangent the tangata sign in kaiapoi
in the in the walk through through on
williams street you know the the rusty
court and steel
one with the carvings in it that that's
being moved out of there and again
that'll probably go on the riverbank uh
why pat have been
tasked to find a place to put that and
that's very simple because it's got
three steel poles that just drive into
the ground you don't even need um
concrete or anything to put it so we're
working on that
um that's pretty much it brian you'll
have seen brian and judith working today
everybody getting all the the artwork
back up in this building and this room
to follow and the corridor and
that's about me
all right let's take you out yes
yes
we should actually acknowledge
councillor the the sculpture kara i mean
and working through his son james
who negotiated at a
very significant fraction of what it's
worth generally as we wouldn't have such
a beautiful sculpture so i'll thank you
that work that was very much appreciated
that was acknowledged
on the day by the black girls and others
so
thanks for the work and getting there
because it's it's absolutely magnificent
it doesn't
any other questions
oh no
[Music]
and
he's going to be acquiring a piece of
art
that will be placed in oxford
that
was painted by a resident in england and
they used also being a very very
high quality piece of uh with the family
want to look to oxford
so you're talking about
i have no questions no urgent general
business so i'll declare the
[Applause]
you